I've decided to watch baseball for
America no other country in the world
can you see something like that
Hey look at this little nerd fighter in
training we are very few nicer places in
the world to watch even baseball than
right here in Missoula Montana the
problem is our team kind of sucks a lot
the season right now we are losing 11 to
2 11 is kind of a high score from the
top of the fourth so little discouraging
nonetheless an excellent way to spend
July 4th the anniversary of our nation's
independence I hope that you are all
finding an exceptionally fun way to
spend your July 4th even if you're not
in America oh oh pop farther out hooray
ok hopefully there no British
nerdfighters who think that we should
not have seceded from your oppressive
rule and so we here Lee celery celebrate
that that success they have a simulated
battle with lots of fireworks which
we'll be seeing soon and famous followed
any dogs and do various other
things that are bad for our bodies in
the environment for America
but sometimes life is just about having
fun I'm doing with cauldre said of the
to do and I just had a hot dog made of
chicken and green chilies was delicious
that's a mini corndogs and some candy
this is America